okay so now we're going to talk about
the phenomenological existential /
phenomenological psychiatrists and their
theories from the 1950s and as I
mentioned to you before a lot of their
thinking was motivated by what had
happened in in World War two when I when
I lectured to you last I I pointed out I
described Nietzsche and Dostoyevsky's
summation of the world situation and
really the world psychological situation
at the end of the 1800s and not was that
our new modes of thinking had undermined
our faith in our old modes of thinking
and that was a problem because people
need something for him to stand on to
orient themselves and to move forward
and so Nietzsche and Dostoevsky
basically both prophesied that the
consequence of that dissolution would be
increased probability of nihilism and
everything that went along with that and
Dostoevsky wrote about that actually
quite extensively in a book called notes
from underground which if any of you are
interested especially in clinical
psychology that's a book you should
really read because it's one of the most
brilliant psychological studies of a
psychologically disturbed man that's
ever been written it's very accurate and
there are sections in crime and
punishment that are like that - I think
they're unsurpassed in their
representation of of sight of
psychological phenomena that was I don't
I don't know how he managed it I mean
Dostoevsky was epileptic I don't know if
you know that but he he was arrested by
the czars men in the late 1800s for
being a student radical and they threw
him and then they in prison in in Moscow
and then one day they took him out in
front of a firing squad and shot him at
6:00 in the morning but they only used
blanks which of course he didn't know
about and that scared him so badly he
developed epilepsy and then he had
epileptic and I weigh it and he had
epilepsy for the rest of his life but he
had this strange kind of epilepsy which
is actually not all that rare sometimes
when people have epilepsy they they
experienced this phenomena they call an
aura which is an altered state of
consciousness before the
elliptic seizure hits and they can be
very strange these auras so I read a
case study once about a guy who his aura
was that his hand was being possessed by
Devils from Hell and he could feel the
possession move up his arm and into his
shoulder and once it hit his head he'd
have an epileptic seizure and so then
there was another case where where this
man his aura was that his exact double
had appeared behind him but if he turn
and if he turned to look then he'd have
an epileptic seizure but if he didn't
turn to look that he wouldn't so these
you know brain disorders are very
strange things because they're well the
system that is disordered is alive and
it's capable of any number of
extraordinarily peculiar missed
behaviors anyways Dostoyevsky's aura was
a world revealing aura and so what
Dostoyevsky would experience was that
the meaning of things got deeper and
deeper and deeper and deeper and deeper
and then just as he was on the verge of
discovering the secret to everything
he'd have an epileptic seizure but he
said that the quality of experience
during the aura was so high so
overpowering and so deep that he would
have traded all of his normal experience
just to have had those experiences and
he had them repeatedly and I really do
believe that it was this broadening of
his of his vision and concept by his
epilepsy that transformed him among
other things I mean he went through some
pretty damn rough experiences because he
was in prison with rapists and murderers
for a long time in Siberia even though
he was kind of an heiress to Craddock
guy I mean he had a he had a rough time
of it and I I imagine that that also
broadened him tremendously given that it
didn't kill him
but I really do believe that the
epileptic in sight was key to his like
his unsurpassed genius and so and the
his aura and other people do experience
epileptic or are symptoms like that by
the way and some people are so enamored
of the aura that they won't take their
anti epilepsy medication because they
don't want to forego the experience that
precedes the aura or the actual actual
epileptic seizure
so Dostoyevsky's experiences the the aw
element of the aura is also relevant to
what we
going to talk about today because both
binswanger and and boss were very
interested in how meaning revealed
itself in the world and they had to know
they had opposing explanations I
actually think they're parallel
explanations but the meaning that
Dostoyevsky experienced is is an
amplification of the normal manner in
which meaning reveals itself in the
world so I mean and people experience
that sort of thing in various altered
states of consciousness
anyways binswanger and vos so they work
mostly in the 1950s and as I said they
were very concerned about what had
happened in World War two and so
Dostoevsky and Nietzsche had basically
predicted that it was going to be
nihilism or ideological totalitarianism
and that's basically exactly what
happened and by by the time the 1930s
appeared on the horizon the Germans had
been you know they'd gone through an
absolutely brutal first world war and
then they went through hyperinflation of
insane proportions so in the 1920s
Germany underwent this partly because
they had such heavy war debts to pay for
World War one the German German
inflation got to the point where it was
literally upwards of a hundred million
marks to buy a loaf of bread you know so
they were taking wheelbarrows full of
money to the grocery stores you know
what happened was their currency
devalued to zero and you know that
actually happens to economies more often
than you might think so the thing just
hits zero and that's that and then it
has to be rebooted so to speak so they
had been the war was dreadful and
hundreds of thousands of men were killed
or brutalized then their economy just
absolutely fell apart and then of course
at the same time well a little bit
earlier the revolution had taken place
in Russia right up you know right at the
end of the First World War and the
Communists had come to power and the
Communists were agitating all over
Europe and in North America and you know
their goal was to to produce a communist
revolution that was worldwide and so the
Germans were all shorted out that the
Communists were going to take over the
country which was a perfectly reasonable
fear and
you know instead of that what happened
was that fascism arose and fascism was a
form of state totalitarianism and I
think the Germans were so desperate for
order by that point that and that's what
the fascist basically offered them at
least in theory unfortunately as it
turned out they offered them a little
bit too much order or maybe a lot too
much order and things went dreadfully
south but you know so then the whole
world had to walk through the horrors of
World War two and and it was shocking in
a variety of ways not only because of
the brutality of the warfare but because
of the genocide actions that took place
consciously by the Nazis and you know
and those actions were in many ways very
difficult to understand I mean here's
why they're particularly difficult to
understand there were certainly times
where the brutality that the Nazis
employed in their eradication of their
theoretical enemies far surpassed the
necessity for the mere eradication but
even worse than that so it went past
eradication into real torture constantly
and not only that there are many
situations in which the Nazis especially
near the end of the war they had to
decide really whether they were going to
continue exterminating Jews and gypsies
and homosexuals and all the people they
felt didn't fit into their culture or
whether they were going to win the war
and there were decisions they had to
make about the distribution of resources
where if they were going to pursue the
genocide elects termination that would
mean it would decrease the probability
that they would win the war not happened
a lot especially at the end and the
Nazis always picked continuing the
extermination now that's pretty damn
interesting you know because you can
think well on the one hand you know if
they are serving a Creed and the Creed
is world domination and this is the
extermination processes are considered a
step towards the actual end point which
is the establishment of a world state of
fascist world state or at least a
fascist European state then you would
think that the extermination attempts
would be subordinate to that goal if
they were actually pursuing the goal
that they said they were pursuing but
you know there's an old psychoanalytic
idea which is really worthwhile
it's like a surgical tool and I would
say if you're going to use it in your
own life use it carefully because you
don't want to do unnecessary surgery and
the rule is and I think this is a union
rule but I can't remember exactly where
I read it if you can't understand why
someone is doing something look at the
consequences of their actions whatever
those might be and then infer the
motivation from the consequences so if
you see someone who seems to be doing
nothing except making everyone around
them and themselves miserable and you
can't understand why one of the
hypotheses that you might entertain is
that they're trying to make everyone
around them miserable as well as
themselves and that's actually their
goal and it's hard for people to
understand these sorts of things because
when we see phenomena like the Columbine
shooters you know we always assume that
the reason that these people are doing
these sorts of things is for other
reasons than the reasons they that the
reasons that appear to motivate them or
even the reasons they say they're doing
it because the Columbine killer
especially the more literate one he said
exactly why he was doing what he was
doing it's as clear as it could possibly
be all you have to do is go online and
read what he said and he tells you what
he was up to but people don't like to
think that way because they don't
believe that anybody could be
consciously possessed of that much
malevolence without there being some
other kind of cause like you know he was
bullied at school or you know he was an
outcast and those things were only
vaguely true and they certainly weren't
more true of him than they were true of
you know how many people in high school
are you know bullied in somewhat
outcasts Jesus it must be 10% it's
probably more like thirty you know that
doesn't mean that the schools are
blowing up all over you know all over
all the time it's a completely
insufficient explanation anyways for
whatever reason you know people turn to
possession by very very strict
ideological ideas and you know they were
willing to be possessed by those ideas
to the point where they would undertake
actions that you'd think would be
completely impossible for theoretically
civilized people you know turned out
that those sick actions not only we're
not impossible for civilized people
but that
the people themselves you know
especially in Nazi Germany they pretty
much knew what the hell was going on you
know you don't take several million
people out of your population without
rumors spreading let's say and so you
know we should never forget that Hitler
was elected you know when he was elected
by a large margin majority - it was a
landslide vote the kind of vote that no
modern democratic leader ever gets so
you know although it's difficult - it's
difficult for people to swallow it's
hard not to assign culpability for what
happened in Germany - the Society at
every strata you can't just dump it on
the leaders and in fact one of the
things that here's here's something to
think about with regards to Hitler so
because one of the things you might ask
is how the hell could he be so so
absolutely compelling to his audiences
but here I'll give you an explanation so
let's let's make the let's make a few
assumptions and the first assumption is
there are a lot of resentful Germans
kicking around why well they lost the
first world war that wasn't so good and
then there were a lot of brutal men left
because they'd been in the trenches and
they'd been shooted at fighting and
shooting at each other under absolutely
abhorrent conditions for like years and
years and so there were plenty of
brutalized men around and then their
whole damn economy collapsed because
they were forced into signing what
historians regard is a very punitive
peace treaty and so like everything had
fallen apart to a degree that we can't
even begin to imagine and so you know in
the 1930s the Germans were starting to
get back on their feet and and when
Hitler came to power he started not only
to rearm but to reindustrialize the
economy and he was actually pretty damn
good at that so now Hitler was a good
orator but he but he it isn't exactly
clear that he was a coherent
philosophical theorize er although to
think of him as stupid is completely
missing the point he was by no means
stupid I wouldn't say that he was
particularly educated but he had a very
powerfully developed aesthetic sense and
he spent a lot of his time designing the
cities that would be built after World
war 2 was over in those cities were
generally conceptualized by him as
places where the arts or at least the
Nazi version of the arts could flourish
you know so there's no real evidence
that what was wrong with the Nazis was
that they were civilized there's more
evidence actually I think that they were
too civilized and I'll talk to you about
that later but anyways you think how did
Hitler get all these people under his
spell well here's a hypothesis that's
basically derived from Union thinking
and I should let you know by the way
because sometimes Young has been accused
of being an anti-semite and there's
various reasons for this partly because
of what happened during World War Two
and partly because his theory drew
heavily from Christianity although from
many other sources as well and he did
believe that there were differences in
the psychology of people with different
ethnicities and now you know whether
that's racist or not depends on whether
or not you like the person you're
talking to because the lefties think
that there are cultural differences and
they're important but if you ever talk
about them in the wrong way then you're
racist and the right-wingers while they
just think there are ethnic differences
to begin with so it's a tricky it's a
tricky issue if there are differences
that are important then who the hell
cares about multiculturalism it's not
even worth preserving and if there are
differences well then you're stuck with
having to deal with the differences so
you're basically screwed either way
so anyways Young has been the target of
many accusations of anti-semitism
particularly by biographers who were
resentful and clueless and historically
uninformed and I would say malevolent
fundamentally he worked as a CIA agent
it was just revealed last year and he he
he provided psychological reports to the
American government on the underlying
psychological structure of the Nazi
leaders for years and he never told
anybody about that while he was alive it
only came to light like it only came to
light as far as I know last year or
perhaps a year before that so so anyways
the Germans you know they weren't very
happy about the whole damn situation and
so when they were aggregating on mass
you think what happens when all people
get together in a group you know we
talked about that last time when we
talked about Kierkegaard's idea that as
soon as you get a bunch of people
together no matter how truthful they are
all as individual
instantly the crowd is not a truthful
thing and you know there there are there
are real reasons for that real
psychological reason so there's the
famous ash experiments I hope that those
are the right experiments a sch about
lime lakes you know so you draw two
lines on the board and they're the same
length and you get the the crowd to you
know collaborate with you and you ask
some poor sucker who doesn't know about
the game to play and you know you ask
one person and they say no those lines
are different in length and you ask
another person they say well yeah
they're quite different in length and
another person says yeah this sure I can
see the difference in length and then
you ask the poor pigeon you know are
they different in length and he says yes
you know and you can understand why it's
like if all those other people are
saying it is either there's either
something wrong with all of them which
seems unlikely or he's the victim of a
conspiracy which is little on the
paranoid side but happens to actually be
true in this case or he's just not
looking at it right and you might think
well the humble thing to think is he's
wrong and so you know the fact that
somebody might go along with a crowd you
know you can you can you can blame that
on their on their ability to be social
and conventional which in many ways is a
huge advantage because if you are all
antisocial and unconventional you know I
mean there'd be a good chunk of you in
jail and we certainly wouldn't be having
this you know delightful peaceful
conversation that we're having so you
know you don't want to underestimate the
utility of conventionality to too much
of a degree anyway so there's this funny
story I read once I don't think it's
true but it might be where a psychology
class got together and decided they play
a trick on the professor and the trick
was that he would walk back and forth
they and and the trick was that they
wouldn't pay any attention to him at all
if he was on the left side of the room
you know they talked bit and look look
up and if he was on the right side of
the room then they'd really focus in and
pay attention and the story goes that by
the you know by several weeks of this
little trick they had him like lecturing
right beside the door you know and he
wouldn't move from that spot and so the
reason I'm telling you that is because
it's
that people can respond to the cues that
a crowd is delivering you know and a
good speaker does that right so a good
speaker does a variety of things and one
is they never talks to the to the crowd
per se you know you pick out specific
individuals and talk to them and they're
sort of reflective of the crowd and then
you can tell if everybody's
understanding and the other thing that a
good speaker does is pay attention to
the damn responses of the crowd because
you know if a lecture is really a
dialogue even though the audience is
only emitting nonverbal the nonverbal
elements of the conversation those
nonverbal elements those damn things are
important so you want to stay in touch
with the nonverbal communications now
Hitler he's kind of a chaotic guy you
know he's very angry he's angry in part
because he was a frustrated art student
he tried to get into art school like
four times so really the person to blame
for World War two was the four person
committee that wouldn't let poor Hitler
into the I believe it was the Viennese
school of art because he really wanted
to go you know and he had some artistic
talent he was a little on the
conventional side I by all appearances
but you know I've seen some of his
sketches and you know he wasn't a
complete [ __ ] and he kind of felt maybe
it would be okay for him to go to
university because it'd just been
through World War one you know and that
wasn't much fun there's a story about
Hitler where he was out on in the
trenches and he was there with all his
buddies and he wandered off to do
whatever he wandered off to do and when
he came back they were all dead because
a bomb had landed right in the middle of
them and he you know you might think
that would do the little something to
your psyche because after an experience
like that you're either going to think
oh man things are pretty damn random and
horrible or there's pretty there's
something pretty damn special about me
because I wasn't killed by the bomb you
know maybe God has saved me for a higher
purpose I mean you can be absolutely
sure that if you went through an
experience like that that something like
that would be rattling around in your
mind and he won he won a medal for
bravery you know so he caught many after
World War one he kind of wandered around
like a lot of men unemployed and sort of
like a [ __ ] you know it wasn't very
happy about that and and you know no
wonder so anyways he didn't get into art
school now
he didn't really have a fully developed
political theory you know and but he was
pretty good at speaking so and there are
lots of people who had come just to hear
him speak because people were sort of
trying to figure out what the hell to do
about all the chaos you know so then you
think well what did hit what was Hitler
good at well okay now I'm going to
switch to a slightly different story and
then I'll get back to this one so I
don't know if you know guys know about
the the daycare scandals that that were
very very common in the 1980s so
horribly common actually this infested
many towns and usually what would happen
is somebody who is a little on the
paranoid side or maybe a lot on the
paranoid side would send their children
off to daycare and that was a whole new
thing in the 80s right because women
were you know moving into the workforce
like mad and so they were handing over
their often their infants kids below
three say to total strangers and you
know for some of them that set up a fair
bit of worry like it still does and
sometimes that worry got out of hand
especially among the people who are
little on the little predisposed to
paranoid schizophrenia and maybe even it
had some previous episodes and so you
know the kid would come home and the
mother would observe or not something
kind of peculiar about their behavior
and then she'd fantasize about maybe
what that was and then you know she'd
start asking the child if the child had
been touched in any particular way and
you know and she keep this up for a good
length of time and then the child would
start to have nightmares and then the
child would tell the mother about what
the nightmares were and then that would
freak her out so she'd ask even deeper
questions and soon you know her children
were telling her that horrible things
were happening to them at daycare and so
then she'd go to the police and they
wouldn't look into her psychiatric
background and then the police would go
out and they'd start to interview other
children and if they interviewed them
properly then the other children would
start to produce all these stories as
well because the now how did that happen
well a bunch of ways the first is the
police would ask leading questions like
did anyone touch you well of course I
won't touch the kids I mean people touch
kids did anybody touch you there well
that's not a question
that's a piece of information the piece
of information is if someone touched me
there an adult would be very interested
in that right so now what's a child
doing when he's answering and adults
questions well child doesn't bloody well
know what the hell do they know they're
like three you know they can hardly
organize their story you know if you're
talking to a kid and you want to give
get them to give you an account of their
day you have to really guide them
through the organization of their memory
and partly what they're doing when
you're doing that is they're looking at
you trying to figure out if they're
telling you the right things which is
what they should be doing because what
they're trying to learn to do is to tell
people things in a way that they'll
understand them but that makes the child
very very responsive to the nonverbal
and verbal cues of the adult do you
think about how fast those little rats
learn how to pick up language you know
it's really very fast and no one really
teaches them they're just paying
attention like mad so you get a bunch of
cops who are on a like a half-cocked
adventure and they think there's some
serial sexual pervert in their midst and
they go interview you know 15 20 kids
and they do it do it do it a lot they
use little dolls and they do it a lot
and they do it a lot and they do a lot
and sooner or later all the kids start
having nightmares and then they start
telling the cops there's also these
terrible things happen like they're
taken into underground caverns and
they're stripped naked and they're
forced to like leapfrog over each other
and like you just can't believe it what
happened you can't believe it it's all
documented in a book called Satan's
silence which was written by a social
worker and a lawyer it's mind-boggling
the longest prison sentences in American
history were handed out to it to a
series of middle-aged women who were
taking care of little kids and the FBI
even came up with a whole new criminal
category late onset female sexual
offender well why did in that category
exist before it's simple there are no
late onset middle-aged female sexual
offenders that's why we didn't need the
category but once all these accusations
came up well poof you know you had to
have some damn category for these poor
women some of them were put in jail for
350 years which seems a bit excessive
that they're only going to last about 40
you know they get 12 consecutive life
sentences so it and you know there is it
actually a situation where one town went
so far as to start digging underneath
the town to find these underground
satanic lairs where all these weird
ritual things were going on you know and
along with this was not one shred of
collaborative concrete evidence you know
and the eventual conclusions and
disaffected thousands of people the
eventual conclusions was well there
there actually isn't anybody who's you
know satanic Lee torturing children in
daycare centers now now anyways why am I
telling you this
well what the children were doing you
think about how the hell did the
children come up with these weird ideas
you know I mean first of all we should
note the children are not stupid and
they can also dream up the more horrible
things you know because they have an
imagination that's capable of extending
itself out into the terrifying now
everyone knows that because all you have
to do is remember when you were a kid
and you know when you were hiding under
the covers because there were horrible
things in your dark room you know you
can populate the darkness with monsters
with no problem and you should be able
to because there are monsters in the
darkness even though your parents might
tell you there aren't it's like there
might not be any monsters in that
particular piece of darkness and that's
a perfectly reasonable thing to tell
your children but in the darkness as a
whole it's like yeah look the hell out
so this children aren't stupid now so
then the pair the adults start to
question them and the kids are the back
of their brain that a little imaginative
part is thinking what are these people
want what do these people want what do
these people want and so they'll throw
them out a little bit of information and
they'll the adults will perk up they'll
focus right on that piece of information
so maybe it's a cop who really hates
child Satanist abductors which you know
is perfectly reasonable stance and so
when the child offers any information
about about the existence of such a
thing while the cop
up and then the child thinks oh I see
well so sort of what's going on seems to
have something to do they don't think
this consciously you know but their
imagination is working how do i model
the reality that's been presented to me
and that's when the dreams start to kick
in - okay
so by speaking in the appropriate way
you can get all sorts of things turned
up and in the in the unconscious minds
of your listeners and by watching them
as well you can extract out their
unconscious desires so now I'm speaking
to you all and you're all irritated
because your life has been really awful
for fifteen years
and I'm saying this and I'm saying that
you know and then I say something maybe
I say something
initially ah dismissive of Jews and
you're all mad and there's two or three
people who go yeah and then I think oh
they know that's kind of an interesting
response and then you know I lay out a
couple more ideas and some of them don't
get any response and others you know
people perk right up and and I'm not
stupid and I'm trying to get the bloody
attention of the crowd and so if I do
that fifty times the crowds going to
tell me an awful lot about what they
want especially if I'm willing to follow
them
and I can do that easily because
especially if I can start to work the
crowd a little bit because I can
capitalize on their emotional on their
emotional capitalize on their emotions
and the display of that emotion and I
can learn to play that and then that
turns into a positive feedback loop and
so Hitler's informing the audience and
the audience is informing Hitler and
that's why you believe that Hitler
embodied the shadow of the German people
so that's another reason why you should
be careful what you say and why you say
it you know and why you're looking for
attention and all of those things and
actually what's motivating you and
actually what's motivating the people
who are listening to you because god
only knows where it might go if you're
not careful well actually we do know
where it goes if you're not careful and
it's not pretty that's for sure and to
think that we've learned anything from
that it's like know that that's not
right we haven't learned a damn thing
from it so because we don't want to
understand it now these guys are all
concerned with that sort of thing
they're highly concerned with it now
Binswanger and boss had both been
influenced by Freud and by you you can
see in the bottom right hand corner
there that's a boss with you and and
that's been swinger on the left and boss
at the top there so you know they're
they're pretty thoughtful looking guys
and they were pretty damn smart and they
were quite philosophically oriented and
they had both studied Heidegger and they
both studied Husserl who were German
philosophers on Heidegger actually got
tangled right up into the Nazi movement
and you know his philosophy has been
cast under a cloud of suspicion
perhaps a well-deserved cloud of
suspicion as a consequence of his
cooperation with the Nazis so it wasn't
only stupid people who got tangled up in
this it was pretty much everybody who
got tangled up in it and one of the
things you might be might think about
and this is we're thinking about is that
if you were there for anyone of you
there's a 90% chance that you would have
got tangled up in it you know you
wouldn't have been the person who
rescued the gypsies is like forget that
it's like unless you think that you know
you're heroic
far beyond the average and I would be
very very careful about assuming that
you could assume instead that you would
have been swept along with the crowd
just like everyone else because everyone
else was alright
now part of what these guys were trying
to figure out is in some sense there
were two things there was the the
function and structure of belief systems
and then the nature of that which
transcends a belief system okay so you
know what transcends a belief system is
what you don't know if you use
that belief system right because there
are things outside of your belief system
and they have a nature as well and you
usually run into those sorts of things
when you make a mistake and things don't
happen the way you expect them to or
want them to or desire them to so and
then the other problem they're trying to
solve in some sense is well what's the
appropriate mode of behavior for an
individual in relationship to belief
systems and to the world that transcends
the belief systems and the reason they
were interested in that is because they
thought well maybe it would be a good
about good idea if our belief systems
didn't get so damn pathological because
if they do then you know six million
people end up in ovens or the equivalent
and 120 million people end up dead in
battlefields and you know that doesn't
count the Stellan massacres or Mao who
were you know made Hitler in some sense
look like an absolute amateur
I mean Stalin starved six million people
to death in the Ukraine in the 1930s he
was just warming up you know I don't
know how many how many of you have heard
of the Ukraine famine how many of you
who haven't yeah well think about that
you know how many of you knew mile
killed a hundred million people how many
of you didn't yeah well you might think
about why you don't know that you know
you know about the damn Nazis but you
don't know about the horrors that the
communists perpetrated it's worth
thinking about why because the
Communists especially the Maoist mad
those people were brutal so it's really
important like of all the things we
could possibly learn psychologically
from the 20th century and is what these
characters in the 50s we're
concentrating on it's like okay things
can go powerfully sideways it was quite
a shock to everyone because in some
sense you know everyone was pretty
thrilled at the beginning of the 19th
century that religion classical religion
beliefs had crumbled you know the
Marxists said well the damn religions
were only there to oppress the poor
anyways and to keep the priesthood and
the aristocracy in power
you know you I'm sure you learn plenty
of that in your in your classes that
sort of thinking you know its power
economics related thinking and it's
typical of what what would you say
intellectually manipulative left-wing
thinkers I would say that's basic
either their routine you know they
reduce everything to a single damn
motivation it's usually economics or
power then they explain everything from
that perspective it's like it's so
boneheaded it should be illegal anyways
the Marxists were happy that religion
had collapsed because they thought that
that would eliminate an entire strata of
oppression and you can see that it's not
like the Catholic Church for example was
free of corruption you know it was in
many ways a corrupt enterprise and you
could read it as solely a corrupt
Enterprise in you know to hell with it
it's good that it's gone and you know
the Freudians basically thought the same
way and so did most intellectuals Freud
thought that religion was nothing then a
than a childish delusion that people
identified with because they were afraid
of dying it was a you know it was a
defense against death anxiety look the
Marxist argument in that and the
Freudian argument those are bloody
powerful arguments you know because you
can see it do people use their religious
belief as a defense against things
they're too terrified to confront whoa
obviously you know does the church
oppress people did it oppress people get
it engage in you know conspiracies with
people in power across centuries it's
like obviously you know the question is
well what do you make of that well
partly you make of it that all sorts of
structures do that it's like structures
do that and you know you can't just dam
one structure and think the others are
going to you know it's like the
right-wingers they're always on about
big government how terrible that isn't
left wingers are always on about how big
corporations are terrible it's like well
big is terrible
doesn't matter if it's government or
corporations because things tend to tilt
towards corruption across time and that
has to be taken into account but anyway
so the Freudians and the intellectuals
and the Marxists were all pretty happy
when the religious dream started to come
apart and they believed that the new
edifice is that they were going to
construct fascist and communist would be
so much better than what they replaced
that you know everybody would be
drowning in utopia and
it's kind of too bad that isn't how it
turned out but it's certainly not how it
turned out how it turned out was hmm
sometimes when you tear something down
even if you think it's terrible you end
up constructing something on its runes
that makes the previous terrible look
like the work of rank amateurs and
that's certainly what happened in the
20th century I mean no matter what you
say about the Catholic Church and its
basic barbarism especially when you know
they were involved in the witch hunt in
the Middle Ages it's like those guys
there are amateurs compared to the
fascists in the communists you know they
were counting their victims in the tens
of thousands not the hundreds of
millions
so anyways things didn't go so well and
so by the 1950s especially because the
Cold War started the day the Second
World War ended right and it ended with
the atomic bomb in Japan and the
Russians had the damn atomic bomb like
you know tomorrow fundamentally and both
the Russians and the Americans had the
hydrogen bomb by the early 1950s and I
don't know if you know this you can tell
me how many of you know this do you know
that a hydrogen bomb uses an atom bomb
for its trigger okay so the hydrogen
bombs the atom bomb stands in
relationship to a hydrogen bomb like the
ignition cap on a shelf stands in
relationship to the Gunpowder the atomic
blast just gets the explosion going so
hydrogen bombs they're like way way more
explosive than atomic bombs and so you
know by the middle of the 1950's we'd
pretty much put herself in a position
where and they were building some mighty
big bombs I mean really unbelievable
unbelievably big bombs you know four
hundred times as big as the ones that
wiped out Hiroshima like huge huge bombs
and they're getting pretty damn good at
it you know so by the mid 1950s it was
like we developed enough firepower on
both sides of the Atlantic along with
the missiles necessary to deliver them
which the Nazis had basically invented
in World War two right it was all Nazi
scientists who invented rockets and they
were all taken by the Americans after
the Second World War to work on the
American space program basically
and so by the 1950s we had the missiles
to deliver the damn things too so not
only were the psychologists who were
thinking about things sort of shorted
out about what happened in World War two
for good reason and then of course all
the Stalinist horrors were starting to
be revealed at that point although it
took Western intellectuals like 30 years
before they gave them any credence at
all I think John Paul Sartre was still a
member of the Communist Party up until
1970 was very common particularly among
French intellectuals you know even
though the news was getting out or
careful observers like George Orwell had
pretty much figured out by the by the
late 30s that not all was right in the
paradise of Stalin but you know people
didn't thought he was a right-wing or
didn't listen to him much even though he
was a left-winger so these these
existential phenomenologist they're
trying to figure out okay we got a big
problem here
the belief systems are seriously going
sideways and there's some indication you
know there's some individual
responsibility for that of some
indeterminate nature like if you live in
a country where everyone's turned into a
fascist murderer like is that your fault
well you know it's not obvious that an
individual should be held responsible
for the actions of an entire country but
then again the country is made up of
individuals so it's a very difficult
problem to solve you know and one of the
tenants of Western law is that you don't
hold an individual responsible for the
actions of the group even if he or she
happens to be a member willingly or
unwillingly of that group but you can't
ignore the fact that all these things
were made up of people and then you also
can't ignore the fact that it was
individuals who were doing the terrible
things that were being done to people
you know so in our Schwitzer example one
of the little tricks that the guards
used to do was to you know they'd bring
the Jews off the freight cars a lot of
them had died in the freight cars
because they're packed in there like
this you know so lots of them would
suffocate or the old ones would die or
the little kids would die and that was
okay you know and then along the outside
of the freight cars especially if it was
winter well it's like 20 below and so
the ones on the outside would freeze but
you know you were going to get rid of
them anyway so that was just convenient
most
so then you'd take them to Auschwitz and
they'd all spill out speaking different
languages torn up from their family you
know as miserable as people can possibly
be and then one trick was to have you
know someone who is not quite dead
enough pick up a sack of a wet a sack of
wet salt so that's a hundred pounds and
carry it from one side of the compound
to the other and then back you know one
side and then back and you know you
don't want to be thinking about these
camps as like like a football field
these bloody things were cities they
were big they held tens of thousands of
people and so there's some guard he
thinks that's pretty good joke and it's
not just a few people that are like that
and we found out from the Stanford
Prison Experiment which every
psychologist likes to think of as
immoral you know because we actually
discovered something with it that if you
gave ordinary people the opportunity to
be fascist barbarians in six days thirty
percent of them would be and you know
what we learn from that is that social
psychologists shouldn't run the Stanford
Prison Experiment that's not the right
conclusion to draw so so these
phenomenologist they're all we're all
concerned about this it's like what the
hell should we do about that so they're
starting to think about how belief
systems are constructed and so the first
proposition that they make is that we
should treat the reality that we're
dealing with as psychologists we should
treat human experience as that reality
and so the reality for you from a
phenomenological perspective is
everything you experience they assume
everything you experience is real and
they also assume that you can't actually
get more real than that and so your
consciousness whatever that is is real
and your dreams are real and your
emotions are real and your pain is real
which is a really useful thing to think
if you want to make sure that you're not
going to hurt people you know you kind
of have to think that maybe faint pain
should be treated as a fundamental
reality instead of as an epiphenomena of
some material substrate and so that's
their first perspective and they took
that from Heidegger because Heidegger
thought that Western philosophy had gone
got off on the wrong track you know
three thousand years ago because we
didn't really concentrate on being its
as the fundamental mystery and so the
fundamental mystery is why the hell is
there anything and since there is
something experiential being what are
its fundamental elements and so that's
the phenomenological stances it's
completely it's not the same as a
scientific approach because it starts
with a different presupposition you know
the scientific presupposition roughly
speaking is that things are the
objectively real elements of things are
the most real elements and there's no
sense complaining about that because
it's a proach that works tremendously
well for many many things including
making hydrogen bonds for example but
it's also reasonable to think that well
it might not be the it might not be the
whole truth and nothing but the truth
and maybe you could also suspect that
the fact that we can manufacture
hydrogen bonds also might indicate that
there's something a trifle off with our
fundamental belief systems scientific
though they may be and there was
certainly something that concerned
Heidegger even though he got all tangled
up with the Nazis
so the phenomenologist were trying to
take apart experience as such and they
made some some hypotheses and then some
observations so the first is that we're
going to assume that your experience
like experience itself is real now you
just because dreams are real and pain is
real doesn't mean and like objects that
we can all perceive are real doesn't
mean you should put them all in the same
category like my dreams are not in the
same category of reality as this table
because you don't have access to my
dreams and you have access to the table
but that doesn't even my dreams in my
pains and my emotions aren't real
they're real
so that's the first now you should note
that this is a this is a proposition
what they're saying is let's act as if
that's true and then work from those
premises and see what happens see where
we can get with it and that that's
that's a perfectly reasonable thing to
do because at the bottom of a theory you
also have you always have to put an
assumption because otherwise your theory
would be a hundred percent right and
would cover everything and it doesn't so
you have to throw an assumption
somewhere in there at the bottom and say
okay we're not we're not questioning
that that's the
starting point so anything you have to
do that because you're ignorant you
don't have a full theory so they don't
like the idea that mind can be reduced
to matter they're not playing that game
they're not playing that the game that
the subject is only at the phenomenal
and the object is real they don't
playing that game either and it's partly
because as boss says without a subject
nothing at all would exist to confront
objects and to imagine them as such true
this implies that every object
everything objective is merely objective
in being merely objective eyes by the
subject is the most subjective thing
possible it's a radical claim you know
but here's here's something to think
about when I look at that coke can you
might say I perceive the object and then
I make inferences about its use and then
I evaluate it and then I use it and you
know that is not actually what you do in
fact it's not obvious at all that what
you perceive are objects and if you
think about it
well people weren't perceiving
scientific objects until like 1500 AD or
1450 so there was no objective object
before that so obviously whatever we
were perceiving was not precisely that
because we would have been scientists
right off the bat George Kelly claimed
that people were natural scientists you
know that we're always investigating
hypotheses and trying to disprove them
and so on and it's an interesting theory
and that it's right in a sense but
fundamentally it's wrong we are not
natural scientists we're natural
engineers and when we look at the world
we don't see objects and then in further
use what we actually see is the use so
for example when I look at that coke can
my visual system activates my motor
cortex directly it can do that without
me seeing the damned can consciously to
some degree because there are people
with blind sight I've told you about
those people they say they can't see but
if you ask them which hand you have held
up they can tell you so they might not
be able to see but they can map patterns
from their visual system onto their
motor output you know and that's
basically what Pia
J said we do when we deal with the world
we're embodied creatures you know and so
what we see when we look around aren't
objects there are things we can use and
things that get in our way you know and
that's the theory that was derived
originally from JJ Gibson who wrote a
great book on that called the visual
approach to ecological ecological
approach to visual perception and his
science is a brand of pragmatism and the
pragmatist basically claimed that you
know things including theories and
perceptions have a limited range of
truth and the truth that that the
limited range of truth is determined by
the match between your actions and
outcome so I think this is a coke cat is
that what it is no but it's good enough
for me if I want to drink a bit of coke
out of it
god only knows what it is you know if
you go into Communist China and you
start advertising these things then what
are they because this thing tells a
story right what's the story like really
do you need Coca Cola no it's like it's
a bit of frippery you know it's a bit of
it's not necessary luxury it's not even
very good for you but it's kind of fuzzy
and it's sweet and you get to buy it and
why is that because no matter how stupid
you are in your nutrition choices as far
as our society goes you have the right
to poison yourself in whatever way you
think best befits you and so when you
send this little coke can off to
Communist China this thing screams
stupid individuality all over and god
only knows how it undermines the state
you know and if you don't if you're not
thinking about that you're not thinking
think about what happens when we export
cars what does a car say it says hey you
can go wherever you want whenever you
want you don't have to tell anybody at
all and you can do it in a really
dangerous high-speed manner it's like
you want a political statement wrap it
up in metal and ship that thing off and
everybody goes oh I really like to have
one of those it's like poof communism
disappears with that you know that
there's nothing that says individuality
and capitalism like a personal autumn
Oh Beale you know you even get to
pollute the atmosphere and ruin the
planet with the damn thing but you know
if you have to drive to the corner store
and pick up your damn coke it's like to
hell with the atmosphere so don't be
thinking that the things that appear in
front of you are merely objects because
they're not you know I started thinking
about this for example when I was
thinking about people going down to
Graceland to look at Elvis's guitar you
think what exactly is it that makes a
guitar
Elvis's guitar you know it's not exactly
the guitar because it's just sitting
there like any old guitar you know and
maybe you could even think about it you
could take that guitar out and you can
put another guitar in that looked just
like it and it would still be all versus
guitar cuz no one would know and you
might think well then that's not really
Elvis's guitar but that's a funny thing
because you would only think that if you
thought that Elvis's guitar was the
thing that was made out of material that
was sitting right in front of you and
that isn't what it is that's only one
tiny little bit of it that bloody thing
is is a part of an incredibly layered
reality right I mean the people who want
to go look at that they're looking at it
in some sense because of the magic
that's emanating from it but the magic
is actually real you know the magic is
the effect of that guitar let's say on
the entire culture and those effects are
the damn guitar too and it's weird
because when you go look at Elvis's
guitar you know I'm looking at the
guitar you're looking at the magic and
weirdly enough the magic is actually
real well you can't fake that way if
you're a materialist because you think
that the thing is the material it's like
yeah right I can tell you another story
so when the Emmitt when the Europeans
came to the South Pacific Islands the
South Pacific Islanders because there
weren't that many of them they didn't
have a very highly technical society you
know and so like if you were like Joe
dominant guy in a Pacific island culture
you know you might be able to have a
stone axe like a well made stone axe
because go make a stone axe and see how
long that takes you it's like that's a
bit of work and so if you're a
high-status guy if you really were
your whole life to be at the top of your
damn pyramid you get maybe it had two
axis you know it's like a red-letter day
you've got two axes you know which is
more than any other animal has by a lot
so it's not trivial and then the damn
missionaries come in they and they set
up shop and what do they bring steel
axes it's like that's kind of a downer
you know you've worked your whole damn
life to get these stone axes and that
makes you like head tribesmen and then
you want your kid wanders down to the
local missionaries and they say oh we
got an extra steel axe here why don't
you take that back home and it's like
it's so shocking because not only did
the missionaries have this thing that is
so much better than a steel axe it's
like a jet plane compared to a to a
wheeled cart like they're really really
different but the missionaries they
don't even notice that's the horrible
thing about it it's like they give away
this thing that has a virtually infinite
value and it's like well it's okay we
got you know a couple dozen of those sit
in the storeroom and you know we're just
willing to hand them out it's a little
demoralizing it was a little
demoralizing for the Pacific Islanders
and so you know what was it an axe that
the missionaries gave away it wasn't
you'd think that if you were a westerner
and you had a bunch of axis it's like
yeah that's an axe it's like yeah right
it's a lot more than an axe a lot more
it's a weapon to bring down a whole
culture accidentally
one of the things that the
phenomenologist claimed is a cool claim
I didn't know they claimed this it took
me quite a long time to figure this out
because I thought I'd figured this out
on my own but it turns out that's very
difficult to figure out anything on your
own now when I was doing my
investigations into how the brain works
from a neuropsychological perspective
not was informed a lot by Jeffery gray
who we're going to talk about later one
of the things I noticed was that you
don't actually you don't actually see
things when you first see something in
fact when you first see something you
don't even see it you react to it you
rack to with your body so I can give you
an example so you you have a partner and
you have a trusting relationship and
then you find out that they're you know
they tell you or you figure out from
their phone or something they're having
an affair and you look at them and you
think what do you see and you think you
see well you see the person it's like no
you don't you do not see the person
that's wrong what you see is a huge pit
that you're going to fall into and you
don't even know you see it but your body
knows that's your blood pressure goes
through the roof and your heart starts
to pound and you sweat and the reason
for that is your body sees what you
can't see and what it sees is something
it seriously does not understand it does
not understand it
it sees the territory behind the map
right because when I look at you for all
intents and purposes really what I'm
looking at is my presuppositions about
you and because you're polite and well
behaved you're gracious enough to act in
accordance with those presuppositions so
I don't even really have to look at you
and thank you very much for that because
it's very difficult to look at people
because they're horrifying and profound
creatures and so everybody walks around
behaving so we don't terrify the hell
out of each other all the time
now when someone betrays you it's like
poof presuppositions gone ok what's
there well god only knows and that's
what your body reacts to and that's
partly why the phenomenologist said we
react to meaning first we don't react to
the object it takes a long time to see
the damn object
so for example let's say that your
person has betrayed you
now you think you knew who they were and
you thought you knew who you were hah
guess what you're wrong you don't know
who they are and because you're such a
[ __ ] that means you don't know who you
are and it means you can't trust any of
your memories with that person and maybe
none of your memories and any intimate
relationships at all plus what about the
future well so when you look at the
person what do you see you see all that
it's like chaos whack that's what you
see and that chaos is the meaning behind
your presuppositions and that's why the
phenomenologist would say meaning shines
forth that's famous die it shines forth
and that's the primary thing we
encounter it's like that's smart and you
know what's really weird that's how your
damn brain is organized and that's weird
eh because you think let's think about
it how do you define reality that's a
tough one so I would say most of you
define reality like your Isaac Newton or
maybe like your Democritus who was the
first person who hypothesized atoms and
so in the Newtonian world
it's like billiard ball world right
everything is made out of little
billiard balls and they bang together in
a causal way and you can predict the
consequences of their banging together
and if you extend it enough you can
conjure up an entirely deterministic
world a happens causes B because a C
always the same way and everything runs
like a giant clock that's Newton's model
and it's and it was a clock model
because you know back at that time
clocks man those things were pretty damn
impressive Clark's got the whole
industrial revolution underway and you
know medieval cities would put an awful
lot of time and work into their clocks
and they thought those damned things
were really cool you know they could
keep track of where the planets were
moving it's like that's a big deal a
clock and if you want to think about an
invention that changed the world it's
like the clocks a big one now we can
measure time in the same way everyone
can measure time it's a big deal so the
idea that the universe is like a clock
given that the clock can predict the
universe it's a pretty damn powerful
idea turns out that it's wrong because
you know causality is a mess
no one really understands it and there
are levels of analysis at which
causality just in the way we experience
it doesn't seem to imply it apply at all
you go down to the subatomic level it's
probabilistic you can't predict single
events and I don't believe that you can
predict the future
you can predict parts of the future in
an extremely limited way for some
purposes for some span of time that and
you can't even predict how long that
span of time is going to last you know
and some things seem to be more stable
across more situations and more times
than others but there's still there's
instability everywhere it makes it
predicting things a very difficult thing
to do so okay so that's one idea about
reality that's the idea really that you
have and that's the reality that you've
been educated to have the idea of
reality you've been educated to have
even though we know it's wrong like it
Einstein blew that world up in the early
1900s along with the various people that
Einstein dependable that's gone it's
wrong and then there's all sorts of
other extremely complicated problems
like how to model positive feedback
loops you know that sort of gets you
into chaos theory and it's really really
hard to model positive feedback loops
and they can go wild in 50 different
ways and you can't really predict them
because they depend on initial
conditions and and so on and so forth so
so the deterministic world it's like no
that's wrong I think part of the reason
we have to have freewill is because we
can't act deterministically you know a
deterministic system is only going to
work in a system that stays the same you
know so you can wind up a little clock
you know one of those little clockwork
toys and it'll walk but you know if you
put a cliff in front of it just walks
off the cliff
soin cliffs are appearing in front of us
randomly all the time so I can't even
see how a deterministic system could
possibly work to guide us it would
assume that our knowledge the knowledge
that we derive from the past is
sufficiently accurate to causally guide
us into the future it's like no that's
not right
it doesn't that maybe that's why we have
consciousness no one knows but that's a
good theory if there's a why anyways
here's an alternative the alternative
this is a Darwinian alternative so
here's the alternative
the world's a complex and dynamic place
it's full of weird things basically it's
made up of patterns it's made up of
patterns and patterns of patterns and
that's what it is and they shift and
dance around and then you throw
something that's alive into that it's
it's programmed by DNA and the damn
thing has to keep up with the patterns
and they're changing all the time some
of them are kind of stable but they're
pretty damn fluid so then you throw the
DNA in there and it goes and produces a
million variants of whatever it's going
to produce and most of them are wrong so
you're a mosquito you lay a million lay
eggs it's like so that's a million bets
about how the future will causally
unfold and the bed is the future is
going to unfold so this egg can turn
into a mosquito and so then you might
say well how often is the mosquito that
lays the eggs wrong and the answer to
that is if it if it lays a million eggs
in its lifetime I don't know how many
eggs mosquitoes lay but they lay a lot
all of those eggs are going to die
except one
if the mosquito is lucky and you know
that because we're knee-deep in
mosquitoes right if it wasn't the case
then there just be mosquitoes everywhere
and there aren't thank god there's
enough of the damn things but you know
so basically what's the bet that is
mosquito matches environment answer
wrong except once in a million so how do
you overcome that million mosquitoes
million eggs and little do the trick and
so look that's so interesting because it
means the fundamental hypothesis that
the mosquito structure matches the
structure of reality is wrong at a one
in a million it's wrong at a 999,999
level of error you might just think
that's just completely wrong you know
that's really wrong but it keeps the
damn mosquitoes going okay so then this
propagates across time you know and what
really propagates across time is a
massive wave of death virtually
everything fails 99.9% of the species
that ever lived or extinct it's
something like that you know and we're
doing a fair good
robbed of making sure that a good chunk
of the ones that exist now are going to
go extinct you know so failure and death
is the norm and it's going to happen to
all of you so if the underlying
structure of reality is mutable which it
is and the only way that you can adapt
to it is by generating variants and
having most of them perish except for
the ones that managed more or less by
chance to keep up how do you define real
and a Darwinist would say and this what
a pragmatist would say to you embody
real to the best degree that real can be
attained and it's not very good your
real is only good enough for about 80
years but you know what else they would
say is that's as real as it gets the
whatever reality is it's so damn
complicated this multi-layered pattern
array that you can't even model it
without using death as the as the as the
mechanism you can't do it and even if
you do use death it's almost all death
and even for the parts that aren't death
which is hardly any of it your damn
solution isn't that good you know you're
going to wear out in 80 years and that's
you got three billion years of trying
behind you that's the best you can do 80
damn years you know maybe if you're a
parrot you can get 150 and apparently
there's some immortal jellyfish which
figures would be the damn jellyfish that
would be immortal so real might you know
that's a whole different way about
thinking about real now you know
Nietzsche said life is truth truth
serves life sorry and that's a Darwinian
idea even though he didn't take it from
Darwin it's like there isn't anything
more true than what evolution reveals as
the model for reality that's as true as
it gets for us and that's not a
Newtonian reality it's a multi-level
patterned chaotic reality that we're
trying to keep up with and that's real
and so what that might mean is that the
implications for action that I derived
from that phenomena
might be more indicative of what it is
than an objective analysis because your
truth the degree to which you you embody
truth insofar as it can be determined
with in a Darwinian framework is
entirely measured by your success in
living and propagating and that's it
there isn't anything under that now
maybe there is but if you're a Darwinian
that's it and I think Darwin's right all
things considered and Newton is wrong
plus we also know that Newton is wrong
now the whole Darwinian thing is more
complicated than we thought because you
you know you've run do you know what
epigenetics are how many of you know
about that well that's pretty good so
your biological education like
demolishes your historical education how
many people don't know what epigenetics
is it's okay it's just relatively new
anyways it turns out that your parents
experience can alter their genetic
structure in such a way that it alters
your genetic structure it's like oh
that's something we didn't expect that
that's for sure and nobody knows what
the final you know consequence of that
will be but it looks like there's more
to the evolutionary story than mere
random production and natural selection
there's more to it than that
who knows how much so anyways when the
when the phenomenologist say we react to
meaning first that kind of opens a
question is like well is that is the
meaning real and that opens another
question which is what do you mean by
real and then that opens another
question is like well is it Newton real
or is it Darwin real well Newton is
wrong that leaves Darwin and Darwin real
that's about as real as it gets
in fact that might be as real as it gets
you know if a partial entity is trying
to model a complex totality all they're
ever going to be able to do is embody a
partial representation of that and it's
not going to be that good but it's going
to be as good as they can get and that's
as true as it can get
so the phenomenologist you know they
have this weird idea we perceive meaning
it's like guess what that's how
your brain is set up you first perceive
meaning and then with a lot of work you
turn that into an object perception
Christ god only knows how much
exploration you have to do before you do
that you know how long do you think it
takes a child to handle it's it's a
soother before it builds up an accurate
representation of the soother you know
it's going to be chewing on that thing
like mad it's going to be taking it out
and checking it out turning it around
and banging it against things and it has
to do all that
including the tactile interaction and
the experimentation with the thing
across situations to establish say
object permanence has to do all that
before it can see the thing you know
like early ie ie AI researchers who were
basically under the influence of
behaviorists who basically said the
object is given and so they could treat
the brain like it didn't even exist you
know the objects just there you can just
see the world it's like that turned out
to be seriously wrong it's damn
difficult to get a computer to see the
world now it turns out you have to put
the bloody things inside bodies before
they could even do it because you really
can't perceive the world without a body
because perception is for bodily action
and without the framework within which
because really what you're doing this is
a Piaget an idea - this is a pattern
this thing and then and the pattern
exists at multiple levels including say
the advertising level and your memories
of coke and all the bloody jingles you
know and all that but this when I look
at that I map its pattern onto my retina
and the pattern is a pattern because
it's extending across time right so it's
not like smoke it's not just dissipating
there it is it's staying there across
time I map that onto my retina and then
the retina match is it onto my hand
that's the coke CAD and actually the
coke can is all of this and you might
say that's not what it is because it's
made of aluminum it's like yeah yeah
it's made out of aluminum but that's
only one part of what it is and it's not
necessarily even the most important part
because it could be made out of plastic
and you know what the hell difference
would that make you know so so it's
pretty damn
weird when you start to think about it
because people make the claim that
meaning is at the phenomenal it's like
there's no real meaning the universe is
this dead thing and if we all went
extinguished you know tomorrow there
just be a bunch of meaningless marbles
rotating in space well first of all even
that's not true because god only knows
what's out there if there's nothing to
perceive it
you know the physicists tell us it's
more like a vast potential fluctuating
quantum field you know and maybe it
doesn't even turn into stars and planets
until there's someone to look at it you
know and you might think that's
ridiculous but if you think about it for
a while you'll see that there's really
something to it you know because you are
the thing that specifies the level of
analysis right you know the way you look
at the world you don't see the atoms you
don't see the subatomic particles you
don't see the little rocks you see
planet sized things when you look out
into space and you know you see it at a
particular slice of time
that's part of maybe your refresh rate
is something like 60 Hertz so what you
see is the universe sliced into 60 Hertz
slices and you think that's real it's
like yeah yeah so is all the rest of it
including its huge expanse of time from
beginning to end you don't see any of
that it's there so what's there all
those things at the same time and what
is all that add up to the physicists
seem to be telling us it adds up to a
pool of quantum potential that isn't
realized until there's something that
conscious conscious that interacts with
it it's like who knows now you've got
your meaning shining forth like mad and
I think part of the reason that children
are so attractive is because for them
the meaning is just shining at them like
that that's why they're always wandering
around like this you know and it's
really fun to watch kids because they
give you a taste of that again you know
because kids have to pay you so you
don't throw them out the window because
they're very annoying right they're
always crying
they're completely useless they just lay
there and they don't do anything you
know and they wake you up at 3:00 in the
morning and annoy you and so you know
because you're selfish and mean you need
some something in return and so they
smile at you and but they do other
things they're really really
really really really comical so they're
a blast to watch and play with but one
of the things they really do is they
they remove the blinders from you while
you're around them because you know you
go out like a little forest with a two
and a half year old it's very annoying
because the bloody things they just
wander around randomly you know so
you've got no goal-directed nothing
goal-directed is going to happen with a
two and a half year old but that's kind
of cool because it frees your mind from
your goal-directed narrowness and you
can watch the two-year-old look at all
these things that you haven't looked at
for twenty years because you already
looked at the once and now you just have
to see your memory and then you think
wow that really is cool you know they'll
bring you something and they'll tell you
what's cool and you know maybe it's a
shiny piece of aluminum a gum wrapper
what you think it's a gum wrapper
because that's what you see when you
look at it because you've already built
up gum wrapper representation and you
just lay it on that that isn't what the
kid sees god only knows what they're
looking at you know maybe how the light
reflects off the aluminum prismatic aliy
and how it glitters and how cool it is
that it can be folded up and how light
it is it's like and they're looking at
it like this and you know I think it's
because their cortex isn't very well
developed and they haven't built the
inhibitory structures that stop them
from seeing meaning shining forth you
know and you might think well is there
any evidence for that and there actually
is quite a bit of evidence for that you
know I mean one piece of evidence is
that if you take a cat's brain off out
and you just leave it with a
hypothalamus and a spinal cord it's
hyper exploratory it runs around like
everything's interesting it's pretty
weird behavior for a thing that doesn't
have a brain you know you kind of think
that once you don't have a brain nothing
would be interesting it depends on how
much of your brain you have and there
are people who have experienced that by
the way there was a famous case of a
conductor who had a very serious brain
injury and it basically blew out his
hippocampus
so he couldn't put any more information
in from short-term attention to
long-term storage and he wrote these
articles these massive page long
journals multi-page long journals and
only write is it's as that as if I'm
seeing everything for the first time
it's as if I'm seeing everything for the
first time
first time and he was wandering around
in a constant state of awe you know and
his wife would come to visit him he
couldn't remember any of the things that
had happened to him and he'd just be
blown out of the water to see her you
know because he didn't see his memories
and he'd say it's just like I'm seeing
you for the first time and you know he
was he was seeing her for the first time
because the access to the inhibitory
structures that were directing his
attention were gone he was an
interesting case too because now and
then he'd sit down to play the piano you
know and he'd have an epileptic seizure
and then he could play the piano and he
could play just like he used to play you
know so it was like he had to switch
brain modes and the mechanism for
switching was damaged so we'd have to
have a little seizure and then he could
lay out these like Beethoven sonatas
like a mad dog and then at the end he'd
have a little seizure and he'd come back
- it's as if I'm seeing everything for
the first time you know and I think part
of the reason that psychedelic drugs
proved so attractive to people in the
60s and have proved attractive to people
since the bloody beginning of time is
because in some sense that's what they
do it's like poof your memory
representations they're gone and what
are you seeing god only knows but it
isn't what you expect and maybe it's
what's there well maybe not too
all right so I'm going to sum this up a
little bit what do you think drives
people to extreme forms of pathology now
that might be your pathology your misery
your suffering and all that or it might
be your social psychopathology which is
your murderous desire to exterminate
okay well here's a phenomenological
theory the terror management theory is
that you got to build these structures
in your head to get yourself away from
death anxiety right and so really what
the terror management people are saying
is the blinder you are the better and
that's what the positive illusion people
think - now the phenomenologist they
were going at this from another
direction they were saying the meaning
that constantly reveals itself is
nourishing and revitalizing although
it's so powerful it can just blow you
apart so it's a dangerous thing to be
messing with it's like the burning bush
and you you have to build a structure in
order to be able to cope with that
because you have to minimize it to what
you can handle but you need to build the
structure properly properly and
carefully so that the meaning that
reveals itself can be shaped by you into
a world conceptual and practical that
allows the remaining meaning to shine
through in a way that you find
sufficiently revitalizing so that you
don't become corrupt enough to become
Jenna Seidel now that's a good theory
and that's what what the phenomenologist
were on about and that's part of the
reason why the existentialists and the
phenomenal I'll just say don't deceive
yourself about what manifests itself to
you don't use language instrumentally
why because if you do that and twist up
the structures that you're using to
interpret the world through the world
will twist up on you and all that will
be revealed is its horror
and if horror is all that's always being
revealed to you you will not stay
good because you can't under that sort
of pressure
you'll get bitter and resentful and
everything will fall apart around you
because you're not actually modeling the
reality in a way that the positive
meaning can shine through so you'll fail
and you'll become resentful and you'll
become bitter and then you'll be looking
for someone to hurt and you'll have
plenty of justification for it so and
worse and this is Union contribution to
this whole idea this won't happen all at
once it'll happen as a consequence of a
hundred thousand micro decisions that
you hardly even notice where you can be
truthful about something or not in this
tiny way that hardly even seems to
matter but that the consequence of
iterating that across time say three
hundred thousand decisions is that you
can build yourself into the sort of
monster that you would never want to see
in the mirror and one of the things the
phenomenologist would also tell you and
this is something young said as well is
that is the sort of monster that you
probably are and so if you want to deal
with that you have to start taking
things seriously and one of the things
there's two things you have to take
seriously and one is the meaning that
reveals itself to you and the other is
the stance of truth towards which you
approve the stance of truth that you
adopt while you're interacting with that
meaning and the final consequence of
that would be your health the health of
your family on your society and the
health of the entire society at large
pivots on that it pivots on that and
that the way the world moves is a sum
total of all the decisions that all of
us are making all those little micro
decisions and those bloody things echo
like ripples in a pond and so when you
do some little crooked thing that you
know you shouldn't be doing you're
actually warping the entire structure of
reality and what's really interesting
about that is now we know what happens
when you do that what happens is that we
end up with the Nazis and the Communists
and hydrogen bombs and we haven't
escaped from that yet and
hopefully we will but we won't if people
don't learn what the 20th century had to
teach them that's that
[Applause]